[Music]
hi dara
hello hi everyone good to see you how
nice is this for us to be here in person
welcome back to stanford thank you i'm
so glad to be here as you can see we're
all i'm really excited and grateful to
have you here but truly no one more than
me
um
you might not remember this but exactly
two years ago i logged into a zoom and
you were my alumni interviewer
i don't know what lies you put down on
that paper but
you've really i speak the truth
on multiple levels you've really made
this moment happen so thank you well
thank you i'm so glad to see you here
and thriving
um so
then and now so when i when i when you
interviewed me when i was entering the
gsbr applying for the gsb and now as i
was preparing to interview you
i reached out to a lot of friends in the
industry and i asked them like what do
you know about dara because i wanted to
get some insights and some intel and the
theme that kept coming back there are
three words ambitious incredibly
brilliant and really humble
and i'd love to kind of go back to the
beginning because i think it seemed as
though when people articulated that
about you they were speaking to the
truth of your being and i know a lot of
that's formed when you're young in your
childhood in your upbringing so i'd love
to know where does your ambition come
from and really what creates that
humility that people are so endeared
towards well thank you thank you so much
for saying that you know i have to give
a lot of credit to my mom because
growing up i was that kid you know i
always dreamed big you know that kid
that you're like oh my gosh stop
but i was always so excited i always
dreamed big and my mom would say to me
you know
dar i like your ambition but don't
forget to have ambition with contentment
and that was something that meant so
much to me and it's been my north star
right from when i was a child right up
until now and always will be and i think
when i think about that it makes me
remember no matter how high you are be
humble
and no matter how low you are be hopeful
because things are never you're never at
least i'll say i'm never as amazing as i
think i am and i'm never as terrible as
i think i am right there's there's that
all that space in between and so
for me it's been about
how can i make as much impact in the
world you know my ambition is not a
selfish ambition just about me for me
it's about what it represents i feel you
know there are not a lot of black women
that get to grace stages like this or be
in positions like that and for me i'm
trying to demystify that my hope is that
you know
black women who are coming beside me
behind me can look and be like oh she
can do i could definitely do it you know
and that can kind of infuse them and and
inspire them to go and achieve great
things and i'd love for you know we need
a world where more people in positions
of power reflect the population that's
why i think about how i can contribute
to that in a small way
well early early in your career you had
a humbling moment you described your
career as a failed career in finance and
you were just telling us the story in
the back about how that all kind of came
to being that you started a career in
marketing so i'd love for you to share
that story with um with us now and then
we'll talk a little bit more about how
you've transitioned since
of course so i'll keep it real because
it's the gsb right
um
so i was going through a rotational
program you know one of those programs
where you rotate through investment
banking investment research investment
management and sales entry and i had my
heart set on investment banking because
that was like the thing that everyone
was doing at the time and i was from
nigeria i didn't really know
well i remember how i actually stumbled
into into i walked into
a place where they had free food as a
you know college student to pack some
free food and i show up in my yoga
clothes everyone is in a suit because
this is actually a recruiting event for
goldman sachs believe it or not
as i'm about to quickly leave the room
this man walks up to me and he's a
partner he's having a conversation with
me and he starts just asking me he's
like well clearly you didn't plan to be
here and i was like not really um and he
starts having a conversation with me i
tell him about what i'm doing i'm
leading a fashion show at harvard at the
time called eleganza the other school
you know
and and he and he was like well you seem
very you know entrepreneurial very
driven this is a production with a lot
of people that's management have you
thought about getting to finance and i
was like not really and he gave me his
card and he was like contact me and i
did and i ended up getting an internship
that's how i fell into so it wasn't so
much a something i calculated i was just
kind of following the motion
and as i was going through this program
this partner said to me
he said you know you're good at
investment banking but you're great at
marketing
and i remember when he first said that i
was like hmm
i don't know why i'm not quite taking
this compliment as a compliment and i
think it's because you know he was
telling me okay this thing you're okay
at but this other thing you're really
great at and when i took a step back and
i reflected on it i realized it was true
i love the data driven analytical aspect
of finance but i love storytelling i
love being creative and for me marketing
i blossomed there because that allowed
me to combine my passion right for data
with my passion for telling stories and
kind of bring those things together and
so yeah once he said that i've been in
marketing pretty much ever since i doubt
this man even knows who i am
but it's and i think that's a reminder
when your position of leadership the
impact you can have on people's lives by
the things that you say or don't say and
i think about that a
lot one of the jokes that gets said
about millennials is that we can't keep
a job for more than two years present
company included
um and i think there's a lot of emphasis
that's placed on staying power so being
able to stay with a company for
decades
an entire lifetime etc
one of the things that's really
remarkable about your career is like it
seems to me that you've always known
when it's time to either stay or when to
leave you always kind of make a
transition what appears to be the right
moment and so i'm curious to know how
you
kind of how do you assess opportunities
as they come your way or the ones that
you seek out and what are some of the
principles that guide you in that
decision making
so one of the things i guess the largest
principle that guides me is the ambition
with contentment which i've talked about
but i also think about how i chase
opportunities that create other
opportunities like i ask myself you know
am i able to bloom where i'm planted
or is this a time where i need to go to
grow
and and for me
if i'm still learning and i'm still
growing then i need to stay where i'm at
and i need to continue to bloom
but if the sunlight's gone and i'm not
learning anymore it might be time to go
to grow
so i try to focus on that not so much
how much money am i gonna make or
is this company doing better at this
point in time but i try more to focus on
where can i where can i bloom where can
i thrive where can i contribute the most
that i possibly can and for me it's all
about learning i'm a lifelong learner
and so i think as long as i'm learning
as long as i'm able to contribute to
that to the best of my ability that i'm
going to stay there and i'm going to
bloom when the sunlight is gone i'm
going to say goodbye i'm going to grow
um one of the things i've really admired
about you is how intentional you've been
about professional development i think
here and just maybe in the bay area more
broadly or there are a lot of startups
sometimes leadership is framed as
something that happens spontaneously
like you're walking around one day you
suddenly have a great idea you then
build a 5 000 people company and
suddenly you're in like a crisis and you
have to lead through that crisis but
you've been really really intentional
and so i i want to understand a little
bit more what that intentionality comes
from and also through your experience
and developing yourself as a leader so
coming to a place like the gsb seeking
out an executive coach etc what have you
learned about yourself as a leader
so i really i don't know how many people
have taken touchy-feely are going to
take it into personal dynamics like i
see some hands in the room i love that
class and which was a very painful class
but i loved it very much um you know
there's how you see yourself there's how
other people see you and there's how you
think other people see you and sometimes
there could be a discrepancy between
those three things and i think one of
the things that i learned
at stanford in this inter personal
dynamics class was about the importance
of how to
bring those things together right and
create less of a gap and a distance
right because you don't want there to be
that much distance there's always going
to be some distance because that's just
the reality of life but how can you
bridge that gap and for me i've really
focused and spent a lot of time
thinking
about the impact that i can have on
others and really thinking and trying to
be quite intentional about how
i can't control what you do
but i can control what i do and i can
control how i react to what you do and
just really placing emphasis on
controlling what i'm able to control is
what i've kind of leaned into and what
i've really focused on
um switching gears a little bit to your
career and marketing
so it seems the business environment
right now just seems incredibly
volatile for like a better word and i
just think that's a good word yeah
um i think like the the role of a
marketing team the role of the cmo has
become so critical at this time it feels
like a really exciting time but also a
really terrifying time to be a marketer
but before we begin talking about that a
little more i
would like to know from you especially
knowing that at different companies the
cmo means so many different types of
types of functions types of
responsibilities how would you write
your own job description as it exists
today
so i lead our global marketing
communications and membership team and
marketing kind of com comprises of every
aspect of marketing right product
marketing demand generation creative
consumer strategy and insights um and
then our our communications team
internal communications external
communications and membership is really
you know the organization that focuses
on our subscription business right our
membership business how we continue to
be a place that our members want to be
at show up at and how we're engaging
them at the deepest levels so i think
you know my job is the full spectrum of
marketing where when i think about how
do i
get how do i generate interest and
awareness
all the way to how do i capture that
interest and and and bring you into the
fold into the ecosystem how do i nurture
that and then how do i turn you into an
advocate and someone who not only sticks
around but you help bring other people
in so that's how i think about it
social media has really changed what
marketing looks like over the past few
years
i think it's created sort of this
environment in which martin which brands
especially consumer brands are expected
to be in conversation with their
potential buyers to always be on to have
a voice to have a personality at times
if we think about brands like wendy's or
some of these others that are like very
very active on twitter
i
i think as part of that brands have
become really embedded in the
socio-political discourse that happens
outside of of these like media channels
and so i'm curious about what challenges
and opportunities
that this expectation has created for
brands and how you
address that at peloton
so i think consumers want to know who
you are
that's just the world that we live in
now and i think it's really important as
a brand that you're clear on who you are
and what you stand for i think that's
really important
at the same time if you stand for
everything you stand for nothing
right and if you talk and comment about
everything
your voice starts to become background
noise
so i think it's it's really important
that you're clear on what matters most
to us and why some of you might remember
that question it's a good question for a
brand to ask itself right what's our
purpose why do we exist
and then make sure that you are
standing up and having a voice in those
issues that are most relevant to you but
i like to say to my team this way i'm
like we want to slay in our lane but
there is a lane you know think about
what happens if you're driving on a
highway and everyone is just going what
that is chaos right and i think as a
brand you can get into a lot of trouble
when you forget about that because it's
like wait why are you talking about this
and it it almost can be a distraction to
your actual purpose and mission so you
don't want to be i always say we want to
be purpose-led not cause-led right
because when we're cause-led then we're
all over the place when we're
purpose-led we're showing up for causes
that are in line with why we exist what
matters most to us right and at peloton
we're about improving people's lives
through fitness so whenever there are
things that are in that space we want to
show up there we want to have a voice
there but if it's not directly connected
to that issue you might see us work it
doesn't mean we're not going to take
stances to help our employees and our
team members and different stakeholders
but you might not see us necessarily
being the loudest voice in the room
because
i firmly believe
if you're not going to take action you
shouldn't speak
i believe that why
because you're taking space of people
who are actually taking action and i
think it's performative and i don't
think we should do that i think if
you're actually going to speak about an
issue take action if you don't have an
action you can take maybe you should
allow
the people who are actually doing
something about it for the attention and
the spotlight to be on them so that
you're not taking space away and energy
away from where the momentum is and i
think that's really important as a brand
and then the last thing i'll say on this
issue as you can see i'm very passionate
about it is that i think you think i
think things like this need to be
inside out what do i mean by that you
have to first start charity begins at
home you need to make sure that you are
doing the work internally before you
start talking about things externally
now you will not be perfect no brand is
perfect so it doesn't mean you have
because you will never get a hundred
percent of everything done internally
but the work must begin internally you
start talking about things externally
that you're not doing anything about
internally that is actually i think
going to backfire you on you as a brand
and it can put you in hot water and
we've seen that happen
how do you balance that desire to be
a person like have a personality through
a brand or for a brand to be personable
but also the need to be able to grow
your market or grow your customer base
with so how do you balance doing so
without alienating potentially new
customers
i think i think i think that's a really
good question and that's why i talk
about your lane and when you're slinging
you're like i might not agree with you
but i can respect you do you know what i
mean there are people you don't always
agree with but you're like you that's a
thoughtful perspective i have a
different point of view on this but i
respect you who you are i respect that
you're authentic i respect that you
stand up for what you believe in what
people do not like is what they perceive
as
being performative or hypocritical those
are the two things that i think really
alienate and separate you as a brand
from your consumer when they feel like
you're not being authentic so you're
just saying you're just telling me what
you think i want to hear you're not
necessarily saying what you believe in
or
this doesn't really align with how you
normally show up so i'm asking questions
question mark question mark and i think
that
you know the best thing you can do is
how can you be authentic to your purpose
how can you be consistent about it and
how can you make sure that anything that
you're speaking about you're talking
about you have action to back it up and
you started the work internally before
you started going outside
so you joined peloton at a really
exciting time the company was
experiencing a lot of growth if you
walked by the schwab residential center
at 6 p.m any given night you could see
people in their little windows doing a
class
and that's great it's great thank you
all for being peloton members it's
awesome
and now things have changed peloton like
from the industry standpoint or from the
news standpoint is being
said to be struggling as a business
what are some of the things that you
believe that you will have to get right
in your role knowing that marketing that
growth is sometimes a function of
marketing
what do you believe you have to get
right in your role for this moment for
to be able to continue to grow peloton
so really so i'll start with what has
changed on what is the same right
because i think that's important context
so what has changed is the macroeconomic
climate has changed that has changed
right there was a pandemic
i don't know if you all remember
we were all stuck indoors and now that's
changed we're in a different context so
the macroeconomic context has changed
what has stayed the same
is that people still want to be
motivated to lead a healthy happy life
people still want
an exercise option
an option to move their body and care
for their mind that is going to
inspire them that is going to make them
want to show up
and you know one of the things that i
think is amazing about peloton is that
in spite of everything that's been
through and we've been through some
things it's been a wide range wild ride
y'all but in spite of everything our
members continue to show up and that is
because our focus on improving the lives
of our members and our focus on our
member experience
continues to remain true that continues
to be our true north that continues to
be our north star and i think that it's
important to remember that because i
think if we
take our eye off doing what's right for
our members and putting them first
we can't do that so i think as a
business we've got to make sure that
first and foremost we are serving our
members we are making sure that we're
providing them with an engaging
experience that they want to show up to
every day that's job number one and as a
marketer i need to make sure that we're
doing my organization's doing everything
that we can to support our members and
put them first
then i think the other the other thing
that we're doing is we're making sure
that people understand who we are and
what we do and what we offer right we've
got when we first started out peloton
and i gave all the credit to our
incredible founders um who who found
this out to be true before the whole
world caught up right this idea of
connected fitness right i can get an
engaging workout from the comfort of my
home this wasn't really something people
thought could happen and they built this
they created this category which i think
is amazing
and now
as the world is evolving how do we show
how that continues to expand in this new
macroeconomic context so we have to show
that yes
you know we were relevant in the
pandemic but we're still relevant now
that motivating incredible experience
that we provided you hasn't gone away
and i think you know we've got the
peloton bike we've got the peloton trail
but we also have the peloton app which
has outdoor running has a variety of
exercises so you don't have to only use
it in the home you can use it in the gym
you can use it on the go and so being
able to really tell that story of how
peloton is really
helping to drive and help people stay
fit be motivated not only in one space
but in multiple spaces that omni channel
experience i think that's really
important so that's something as
marketers you know that's that that's
job number two
so
looking internally how are you leading
the team the team that you you head and
then also thinking about the executive
team as well through this critical
inflection point
leadership leader i think it's so funny
because i think you
everyone's like leadership all right
welcome to my ted talk um
you know i think it's so easy to think
you're a good leader when everything is
going great you know what i mean it's
like oh i'm a great leader well maybe
it's just a macro economic context
um i think it's harder to lead when
things are tough right it's harder to
lead when things are tough and i think
that's really where who you are shows up
and the impact you can have on other
people's lives show up and i think my
number one thing is i'm a people first
leader
i believe that to the core of who i am i
treat people how i want to be treated
and that is fundamental to me in my life
and in my work and i carry that through
every step of the way that means when i
have to make tough decisions i make
tough decisions the way i would want
someone to make a tough decision with me
it means when i have to communicate
difficult news i communicate difficult
news in a way i would want someone to
communicate that to me it means when i
have to encourage someone to change or
try something or do something different
i i make sure that i am putting their
interests first and i'm helping them see
what's in it for them
so i think having that because i think
when things get tough it's easy to take
your eyes off the people and focus on
the problem and actually i believe
that's when you need to lean into your
people the most because you can't solve
the problems by yourself
winning is a team sport
and in order to win it means you need
all the people on the team to believe in
what you're saying to rally around you
and to and to come together to do that
and so i firmly believe in putting
people first and that's something that i
continue to do with my team you know i'm
really proud of this because in my
entire career since i started managing
people i have never ever had anybody who
directly reports to me come to me and
say hey here's my resignation notice
it's never happened
because i always have conversations with
people i always understand hey how are
things going are you blooming where
you're planted or is this a time for you
to go to grow we have honest
conversation my team know they can rely
on me my team know they can be honest
with me and so if it feels so and so
because of that because i put them first
guess what they also put me first they
think about me and they think about the
impact and not only do they pooped up
but they put each other first and so it
allows us to navigate tough times i
think in a much better way
the second thing that i think is really
important is controlling what you can
control there is so much you cannot
control but guess what there's so much
you can
and how do you take the assets that you
have and do something
with what you've got i think so many
times we feel oh well oh only if this
could change you know what can't change
that
but there's a lot you can change so how
about we do a lot with what we had i'll
give you an example i'm a storyteller i
told you at the beginning um you know
one of the things that's happened to us
at peloton
is we have this passionate member based
i see some of them in the room we can
talk about your favorite instructors
after this
um but we have a passionate member base
and what that means for us is as we've
gone through the different things we've
gone through our members have actually
taken to social media to tell their
stories so there was this phenomenon
that was happening which was several
members going to social media and saying
hey i was the biggest peloton skeptic
here's what i actually wrote publicly on
social media in 20 you know in 2018 i
wrote i will never ever use peloton this
is an overpriced coat rack here's what
i'm saying today this thing has changed
my life y'all this is like the best
investment i've ever made they were
publicly going to social media to say
this and guess what many times they were
tagging me by the way this was amazing
therapy to read at the end of the day i
was like you know this is great i'm not
going to twitter i'm going over here
this is amazing and and you know it was
such a motivating experience but yes i
was talking with my team my head of
brand always snotty
and i was like
what if we just turned this into a
campaign and the whole team rallied it
was amazing it was the quickest campaign
we ever everyone was like let us take
this and what is the campaign it's
simple it's literally the person's name
what they said
yeah what they said previously and what
they're saying today that's it that's
the ad and we put it everywhere and it
was remarkable not only did it galvanize
our member base but it was inspiring for
our employees as well it was so great
for people to say you know what there's
always going to be skeptics but they're
also always going to be believers and it
was such a a magical thing and it meant
so much to folks and i think that's an
example of how you can i couldn't
control what everybody was saying but i
could shine a light on something else
that was being said i could shine a
light on what our members were saying i
could amplify the voices of our members
so i think that's an example of how you
can look
sometimes you've got to do a little bit
data mining deep mining but you can look
at what you have what assets you have i
can you can use that to control the
situation and then third thing final
thing i learned at gsp keep it to three
things
um
is communication over communicate i over
communicate every week with my team i
have weekly stand up with everybody in
my organization it's my sacred time
the only time i miss it is like if
there's something super important urgent
that i i almost my husband knows he's
sitting right here even when we're on
vacation i'm like it's stand up time
y'all and i'm like getting in there it's
really important to me that i'm
connecting with my team every single
week guess what during the hard weeks
i showed up
and i remember my team people on my team
said that to me they were like we
thought you were going to cancel
because we were like well she gonna show
up today well this the stand-up's gonna
be lit i'm bringing my coffee to this
what's going on is she good but i show
up when it's hard i show up when it's
easy i show up
on these days i still show up and i
think it's really important how do you
show up are you always showing up are
you communicating are you sharing as
much information as you can with your
team
while you were at stanford like many of
us you
caught the entrepreneurial bug and you
started two companies oh yes
do you want to speak about that
wow well you then went on to build
really big global brands apple ge your
carbon now you're a peloton many of us
are in the stages of deciding whether or
not we want to build or
join
and i'm curious i'd love to kind of know
a little bit more about your experience
to making that decision for yourself
whether you would pursue what you were
building while you were at stanford or
join another company
so the way i think about it i think
about impact right
you can have impact you can have small
impact and you can have really massive
impact and i remember when i first
started when i was thinking i was going
to be an entrepreneur um
my husband said something to me which
was very interesting he was like i feel
like you really enjoy the management
perspective more than like the founder
stuff like going around fundraising like
i was very nervous i didn't want to take
money from anybody i just wanted us to
continue to pour our money and just like
that's not really how it works
and and and i was you know i didn't like
but i loved the management piece i loved
the marketing of it and so you know i
started to have real conversations with
myself because i think that's when at
the gsp everybody when during my class
everybody was like what are you doing oh
i'm starting my own you know my own tech
startup want to come work for me be my
co-founder like it was literally like
everyone was doing that so i kind of
knew i didn't want to miss out i was
like i don't want to miss out like i
don't want to be like the loser of my
class okay i'm going to start something
clueless
shopping something
and and and you know i think the lesson
i learned there is like don't do what
everyone else is doing
do what's right for you
and for me i remember it was kind of it
was very actually humiliating when i
first shut down all my startups
because i would run into people and
they'd be like oh how's that startup
mine's still going by the way i hired my
third engineer and i'd be like
i shook down my startup but i got a job
and i was so humiliated but guess what
like who you know i'm really happy about
the path that i took because it was the
path that was right for me and i'm
saying i'm sitting here because one of
my bosses and mentors joe de
love y'all joe's amazing he's a
professor here too
and i gotta work for for amazing people
like joe joe was the founder and ceo of
carbon and he hired me as his cmo that
was an amazing opportunity right to work
in creating this category of 3d printing
like you know we had the largest use
case of a 3d printed consumer product
out in the wild with these adidas 3d
printed shoes and it was incredible to
do that and for me what i've realized is
i don't yet have an idea that i'm like
if i don't do this idea
like i'm willing to give everything up
for this idea i haven't had so for me
it's like well if when i meet people
like joe incredible people who have
those ideas i want to contribute to that
i want to help them build that and i
think that's how i've for me it's not
about
it's about how can i have the most
impact and so far for me it's about
it's about making the most impact by
being where i need to be at a right at
you know at any given point in time and
for me it's been
joining these incredible companies and
helping scale and grow them as a
marketing leader
so it's okay if you're not starting a
company you'll be all right
on the side you do invest in people who
are starting companies
and so from your perch now as like a
brand expert
i'm curious to know
what signs do you look for when you're
looking or you're evaluating a company
or startup
and you want to and you want to declare
them as having the rights
mix of brand product strategy etc
the passion of the founder i just told
you what i didn't have those people i'm
like yup those people like the people
where i need to build this like i'm
willing to give everything up to build
this i believe in this so much that i'm
willing to put everything on the line
for this that passion because guess what
your founder journey is not like this
that's not how it works my start out
great with that great press article that
comes out oh and then your consumers
don't show up oh and then you get
product market fit the unit of economic
model breaks down oh but then you know
well we got the unit economics to work
oh scaling is really hard and really
hard like you know the journey is is not
linear it's like a jungle gym but if you
have someone with passion i think that's
really important the second thing is is
this someone that people want to follow
do you know what i mean you know there
are those people like joe people you
love you want to work for them you're
like i don't want to like well i'm i'm
excited my husband knows sometimes a
little too i when i'm passionate about
something i'm i'm working for it right
i'm in it and there are people who
inspire you people who motivate not
everyone has that gift i think that's
really important to have as a founder
because not only are you the
idea creator and generator but guess
what you're the first cmo and you're the
first head of sales you need to recruit
and attract people to that idea so
having that magnetism being someone that
people are willing to like yeah you know
what i'm gonna take a risk and and come
join you on this adventure i think
that's really important and then the
third thing is curiosity
whenever i ask
when i'm looking to invest and i ask
questions and the person has an answer
to everything
i'm not going to invest
because the reality is there are many
things we don't know and we need to be
comfortable saying you know what i don't
actually know that
but i'm going to go and i'm going to
learn and i'm going to get back to you
about that
and guess what if they actually get back
to me to give extra bonus points because
many people say that they don't follow
up
you know but it's that curiosity not
thinking you know everything none of us
know everything i feel like we live in
the age of backseat drivers you know oh
my god i read this tweet one tweet and i
know everything backseat drivers will
drive you off a cliff believe that
backstage drivers will drive you off a
cliff so i think it's really important
that people are curious they're willing
to
ask questions and they're willing to
admit what they don't know and it's okay
because i think people who are humble
enough to say you know what i don't know
everything i don't know that those
people always are more successful than
people who think they have all the
answers
i want to switch gears and talk about
identity because i know that racial
justice and gender equity are issues
that you are incredibly passionate and
supportive of
you are so interesting to me
because you
had to sort of learn what it means to be
black in america
every a lot of many people might believe
that being black or black identity is a
monolith but in nigeria where you were
born and where you grew up it doesn't
really this is an ethnicity there 500
other ethnicities in black doesn't show
up there
in london or in the united kingdom where
you went to school and then in the us
that's really where like this racial
construct started taking shape i'd love
for you to share with us what that
journey was like for you and what were
some of the lessons that you learned is
your identity sort of mutated across
these borders
it's so funny because you know growing
up in nigeria
yes everybody was black but there was
colorism which i like to think of as a
shade of racism
and growing up you know
i'm not i wasn't light-skinned
but i wasn't in nigeria i wasn't
dark-skinned i was kind of in the middle
and my sister my older sister is dark
and almost
almost everybody i met we met would
always say oh dara you're so light and
so pretty
you know and that and they would might
look at my sister and they would and and
i remember growing up just hearing that
over and over and over and over and over
again
and you know nigeria is a form of colony
right and it's amazing what that does to
you and what that can do to your mind
and
i should have never told this story
before i don't even know why i'm sharing
this maybe i'm all emotional in the gsp
but
but i remember you know growing up there
was a time where i was like i felt like
i wanted to make my skin lighter
you know i went to the store i didn't
have a lot of money so i bought like the
worst possible cream and i put it on my
skin it was awful i had a complete
allergic reaction i mean i literally
transformed my skin into
and i looked like a leopard i mean it
was not good
and i'm glad that actually happened
because i was like you know what better
to be one color and look great so not
ever gonna do that again but you know i
learned i learned a painful lesson you
know when i was very young but i was
glad i learned that lesson
but when i came to the u.s it was
interesting because i remember someone
referred to me and they were like oh the
dark-skinned girl and i was like oh who
oh who and it was like
they were talking about me and i
remember that was actually my very first
vivid memory where i was like wow
i'm now the one
i'm now the dark-skinned person and then
i also just
all the experiences i had of walking
through sorry it's like harvard yard and
you know
people wondering if i went to school
there and and kind of those experiences
like or or people thinking i was the
cleaner or you know i actually had to do
dorm crew which if you went to harvard
you know what that is it's where you
clean the dormitories of kids and many
times it's the underrepresented
minorities cleaning the dorms of our
rich
white counterparts
and and and that can be painful and it
can be and i remember just kind of going
through these experiences and just
realizing wow when i walk out the door
nobody cares where i am i'm just black
i'm a black woman in america
what am i going to do about that
and i remember asking myself what am i
going to do about that
the time i didn't really have much
i didn't you know but i thought to
myself well how about i try to do the
best with what i have i'm going to a
great school how can how about i try to
be the best leader that i can be and try
to model
what it's like to excel as a black woman
in business that's my what i'm
interested in
and and that's what i've tried to do and
that's
that's my passion that's why i show up
every day no matter how hard it is for
many people i'm the first black boss
that they have
for many people i'm the first black
female boss that they have
and i think about that
and i think about what do i want i think
well some people are gonna walk in here
and they're gonna not have any
assumptions some people gonna walk up
with some assumptions
what can i do to change that
what can i do to impact that i think
about that a lot and so for me my
journey has been about
how i can help elevate black women
how and women of color in general in the
united states
and how i can use my platform to show
and demystify and make people see you
know what if you're a young black girl
you know what if dara can do you could
definitely do it
you know i just really try to inspire
people and show people because you can't
be what you can't see
and i think it's important to see that
it was really important for me
to see ursula burns you know first black
woman ceo of a fortune 500 company that
meant so much to me i've never even met
her i talk about her all the time you do
like people think we're friends no i've
never met her
you're invited to view from the top let
me know i'll come say hi
but like you know but it meant so much
to me and now here we are in 2022
there's still only three
still only three first live burns
ross brewer
that's under ducket that's it it's 2022.
what are we gonna do about that i asked
myself that question
that intersection that you described of
race and gender you spoke to a little
bit in your response
is so
it's so nuanced and i think that i mean
i sit in the same place and it
especially in the u.s i feel it comes
with so much baggage
and so i
what did you
have to unlearn
about that identity in order for you to
be successful
you know when i first started out
i was like i don't want to talk about
anything black like i don't want people
to see me as like oh the you know the
trope of the angry black woman i was
like i don't want that so like i want to
just be easy peasy dara calm neutral
okay to be around never gets annoyed
about anything
and and and you know i wasn't really
showing up as myself because i'm sure
you've already seen i'm pretty
expressive i'm pretty passionate and so
i was just like don't say anything don't
do anything don't be weird
and i just
i just was like a shadow of myself and i
remember this incredible boss that i had
um
and and he was amazing and he he is gay
and so and he's other and one day he
pulled me aside and he was like we other
people come on let's have a little talk
and he said you could be yourself i'll
let you know if you get too [ __ ] how
about that and that was amazing to me
right to have someone that i knew was
kind of looking out for me and he
understood what i was going through how
i was trying to navigate these spaces
and and that's how i think mentorship is
so important and you don't always have
it wasn't the ceo of goldman sachs that
was mentoring me you know i feel like a
lot of times i get noticed from people
hey i would like you to be my mentor and
sometimes i reply and i'm like have you
asked any other black women in your
organization or anybody you know that
has shown an interest in you i think
sometimes we think we need the top of
the leaderboard to be our mentor
um and and and sometimes you know that's
it's actually who cares about you the
most that's who you should be your
mentor who believes in you who wants to
invest time in you and i learned so much
from him
and and and you know it helped me
realize that i could show up more as
myself
guess what i also realized there's a
cost to that
you know when you're the person that
makes the comment oh wouldn't it be
great if we have a diverse slate
there's some people who are not gonna
like that
it's gonna upset some people when you
make comments about hey can we make sure
that we're promoting
because i think about recruit
retain promote and protect
because guess what everybody says they
want diversity when you add a diverse
person to an organization guess what
happens it's like a transplant
you add an organ that the body wants to
reject
it's just the truth because it's a lot
easier when we're all by it's it's
easier when we're all the same it's
easier when we all think the same things
it's harder when we have different
perspectives and points of view it takes
work
are we willing to do the work we should
all be willing to do the work and i
think you know what i've done is
what i try to do every day is make sure
that i'm that voice in the room that i
ask those tough questions that i push
those issues doesn't come without a cost
but what i've also learned is that
there's a time and a place
and as a black woman
what i've realized is many times people
want to know are you really on the team
say that again people want to know if
you're on the team what do i mean by
that
people want to understand why are you
making that comment
are you making that comment just to be
disruptive or are you making that
comment because you want us to be better
so what i try to do is make sure do
everything that i can
to make sure people understand i'm on
the team
but i want us as a team to get better
and that's how i try to navigate it's
not easy and i don't do it well all the
time but that's how i try to show up
as one of the few black execs at peloton
and also in the tech industry just more
broadly i'm certain that you get pulled
into a lot of conversations where it
might not really fall within your scope
as the marketer but it it's so core to
your being
i'm curious about how you manage the
responsibility the weight of that
responsibility of being a steward on
behalf of your community whether that's
black women immigrants etc
and how do you also
like
what do you
what do you believe that others
allies could be doing better
to help so that you don't have to
shoulder so much of that
well i there's a saying it's not my
saying but i love the thing pressure is
a privilege
pressure is a privilege i think about
that
so there are hard days
and during those hard days
i remember i'm here for a reason
i tell i literally tell myself dar
pressure is a privilege
and
when you are in a position of privilege
what are you going to do about it
so i say if i think this is hard how
much harder is it for people who
aren't yet where i am in my career
so i can't be like oh this is too hard
you know what
i tell myself grow up
life's hard
keep pushing
because i have a daughter who's six
years old
i don't want my dog i want my daughter
to be dealing with different things
right i don't want my daughter to be
dealing with this i don't want my
daughter to be having these same
conversations
so that means i have to be willing to do
the work
and i'm willing to do the work and i do
the work
doesn't mean i it doesn't get tough and
that's why i think you need a support
system if my amazing husband was here
and my sister
and my family and my friends
and my mentors rob siegel and you're
here wrong yeah i have a good rob story
we gotta come back to that i gotta tell
you that it's a good one
and and i have these people that support
me and love me right and so i have a
support system and that's really
important because you know what it gets
hard and some days i'm going to go home
and i'm going to cry
and i'm going to be like this is really
really hard
and i need someone
a people to remind me of who i am and
why i'm doing what i'm doing so i think
that support system is so key
and i think that's something that the
gsb and the stanford community really
provides right my very best friend in
the world i met at the gsb
and my husband and i we have every
sunday we even we we have a zoom call
with her and her husband every sunday
you know and she's my sister my support
system we talk about everything so i
think having support system is so key
and so important to navigating that then
the third thing i'll say is protect your
peace
you have to protect your peace
i remember the very first time a press
article was written about me i was so
proud i was so excited i emailed it to
my mom
my mom was like really great
dara you're never as great as they say
you are
that sounds like a nature i know it's
not like a nigerian mother
you exactly never as greedy as they say
you are
that's where the humility but you're
also never as terrible as they say you
are
god is still doing work with you
literally what she said to me verbatim i
remember it i think about that a lot
right and i think that's really
important because when you're doing the
work and you're going through it you get
criticized right are you doing enough
are you doing too much like
you know for some people you're never
doing enough for some people you're
always doing too much
right and then there are people who are
like yay thank god for those people yay
right and you gotta navigate all of that
and so for me it's about protecting my
peace and making sure that i don't allow
those backseat drivers to drive me off a
cliff
my final first question for you so you
alluded to this earlier there's the
infamous question on the gsb application
what matters to you most and why
how did you answer this 10 years ago
when you were applying and how would you
answer this now
that's a really good question i'm going
to answer it first i'm going to tell you
my rob siegel story because i think it's
really important
he's sweating over there he's like why
why is this happening right now
no i think it's really important it's
really important there's a lesson here
before my first cmo job this is a big
deal my first ever c suite job
i was interviewing for it
and i was like i need someone to talk to
rob do you remember this
and i'm like
sos can we have a conversation he was on
a plane flying somewhere he was like i'm
gonna what time is it i'm gonna get on
i'm gonna call you
he called me had a conversation gave me
that confidence i say that because it's
so important to be there for each other
right
and and and that was so critical for me
at the time i had imposter syndrome i
was definitely ready for the job but
guess what i never i'd never done it
before i like to say there's a lot of
half-baked people walking around looking
for fully baked people you know some of
those people like there's a first time
before you do all of us have a first
time
like now i've been a cmo multiple times
but that was the first time someone was
gonna give me that shot give me that
opportunity sue siegel incredible woman
who gave me that first shot amazing
leader
i needed the confidence to know that i
could do that rob gave me that
confidence he sat with me he listened to
me he helped me prep
invaluable
change my life
you never know when you're going to
change someone else's life so when
someone in the stanford community
reaches out to you sos
don't ever be too busy i think about
that now by the way when people reach
out to me i remember rob and i remember
hey i'm not too important i'm not too
busy to be there for my friends and be
there for the people that matter to me
okay now i'll answer your question
thank you so
what matters most to me and why
i wrote what matters most and derek
bolton thank you for accepting me into
the gsb he's over here and i wrote i
wrote what matters most to me is my
christian faith
and it's because it gives me the
strength to live by my values it was
what mattered most to me then
it is what matters to me most to me now
it is what will always matter most to me
my values of love of acceptance of
respect of inclusiveness
you know i talked earlier about treating
people how i want to be treated there's
so much in the world we can't control
i think many times sometimes we
forget about forgiveness
we forget about love we forget about
respect
and it's always about well my way my
view my perspective my thought and for
me
you know my faith reminds me
not just to think about myself but more
importantly to think about others
and
as a leader
my faith inspires me to be a servant
leader
i tell my team i want to serve you i'm
here to serve you
and
for me that's what matters most and you
know at the end of the day
when i talked about that protection of
peace
right we're all going to go out in the
world i'm sure i sit here all these
amazing people you're all going to start
companies maybe you'll hire me tech ceos
up there
um and and you're gonna build great
things and you're gonna do great things
and i think it's really important not to
forget for me it's my faith but you'll
be something else right you know one of
my best friends is an atheist like i
don't get this whole thing i'm like
that's okay you know for you it's going
to be something else but whatever
matters most to you and why don't ever
forget it and don't lose sight of it
thank you dara you are truly remarkable
and i knew that when you interviewed
me um we're gonna turn to some audience
questions
hi dara um first of all thank you for
being here my name is melanie i'm in mba
too
um i also wanted to say a big thank you
to your family i actually went to life
fort um when i was
and that was a really big transition for
me when i was moving from london
and i was crying i used to cry a lot at
the school and your mom used to make
pancakes for me in the house
so thank you so much
they're all my favorite food um but my
question is one about family life um and
i know that men don't often get this on
this stage but it's so important
yeah it's so important for us as black
women in the school we often talk about
that there aren't enough leaders in
front of us that can talk to us about
our lives outside of work
um and so i wanted to talk to you about
you know
how you how you balance everything but
not just that how you
are very intentional about you know um
the qualities in your heart in your home
um looking after your kids raising that
family in the us as an immigrant there's
so many questions in this but it's
really just about balance and family and
the choices that you made
i'm also interested in the answer to
this question
that's funny that's my husband he likes
the joke
um
so
look i'm gonna keep it real right
there is no balance in my life there is
only harmony
you know many times i'm out of balance
sometimes you know it's been a year for
me i don't know if you know the year
i've had it's been a year
and and you know what
work has come first a lot of the year
and i'm so blessed that i have an
incredible husband who also has a career
so we're a duo career couple do a career
family
but it's not my job to raise the kids
it's our job
and we're thinking about that and we're
looking at that and guess what sometimes
when things are really crazy for me he's
like okay i'm lead parent now okay so
you're not just gonna breathe in here
with your 30 seconds of thoughts and
breathe out i make the pancakes how i
want to make the pancakes she just said
pancakes so it's in my head you know and
and and and i think that's really
important that partnership is so key and
so important but the other thing too is
i tried to do with my dog with my kids
you know i have a daughter who's six and
a son who's four and my daughter who's
six she kind of understands things a
little bit more now as i have
conversations with hey what's really
important to you she's got a she's got a
musical coming up on me
in may it's very important to her
it's in person
you can join on zoom but it's in person
and she said to me mommy
this is in person
and i want you there in person
you don't know my daughter is zoeyasa if
you do you're like yes ma'am i'm gonna
show up there in person but she you know
so she has that ability she knows i've
created that space where she can express
herself and she can tell me what she
needs to i know what's really important
so guess what there's something really
important happening on my job and i'm
like
i'm going to be in person at my
daughter's school that day that is not
there is nothing that is going to keep
me away from being there now am i at
every she has gymnastics
am i at every single gym no i'm not i'm
not going to lie i'm not going to sit up
here and tell you that because it's not
true i'm not at all her little i'm not
at everything but the things that matter
to her i'm there and i show up for that
so for me it's about i kind of think
with objectives and key results so i
have my objectives and my goals the
things that are important to me and i do
that another one with my husband you
know we every year we try to go to a
marriage retreat we try to do it every
year
no matter how challenging it is we make
space for that
it's an objective it's important we sit
there think about our vision what are we
gonna do well you know we we plan we're
intentional that works for us doesn't
work for everybody not everybody needs
that some of my friends are like why why
not necessary we love it works for us
right do what works for you but it works
for us that intentionality and so for me
it's about creating those space being
stubborn about the things that matter
most to my family i'm making sure that i
prioritize that and the other things
there's no balance like i said
there's harmony
one more
hi um thank you for being here you're
really captivating so it's been awesome
to speak um different from the family
life going back to organizations i think
one of the things that my prior
organizations struggle with especially
during the pandemic um is an experience
of athletics as well is how much
leniency and understanding do you give
to your employees in hard times and
whether that be in their personal lives
or at work um and you seem like you're
exceptional at managing teams um how do
you balance being an understanding
leader with hardline expectations on
work um showing up like you said and you
know expectations that your team display
grit and determination you know that are
concomitant with being in an ambitious
workplace environment
so i'll answer that question with this
story
you know
in
everyone is going through a journey even
if you don't know it and you don't know
what that journey is
and for me
having constant communication and being
open with my team and keeping it real
you know i really try to keep it real
don't do it well perfectly 100 of the
time but i always try to show up as my
authentic self and i always try to keep
it real and what that means is i
i ask questions and i and people the
people that work for me that are closest
to me know they could tell me exactly
what's going on
so i was talking to you know someone who
worked for me
at a job
and the person told me hey
you know the person has had a
very very big job
and they were like this job right now
for what i'm going on in my personal
life this is a lot
and i don't know if it makes sense for
me to keep doing this
you know and we had that open and honest
conversation
right
and
that helped me understand oh wow
this is a lot how can i support this
person
and so i started to think about how i
could support
and and make sure that they have the
team around them to support them and
i'm able to support them but ultimately
the person decided you know i'm not sure
that it makes sense this type of job
makes sense for me anymore
and i remember when he called me to tell
me
was very nervous
and thought i would like talk him out of
it i didn't i asked him why
and when he explained to me he said you
know when i first took this job i worked
till 10 pm
that day and i haven't stopped
and it's been several years
i have young children i have family that
live abroad like i just i need something
different it made sense to me right and
so i asked him well what do you want to
do and he said i ultimately want to
leave and i was like how soon
and we talked about it and we worked out
a plan a beautiful plan
that worked well for me for him for the
organization for the company and i think
this comes back to like being people
first right ultimately i'm like what is
in the company's best interest is a lack
of disruption
right that is ultimate for a leader this
big that is ultimately what is best for
the company
but it's also what's best for him so how
can we work together on a transition
plan that is going to make sense i think
often what happens is
and by the way i'm guilty of this i
think we're all guilty of it in some
ways we don't always put ourselves in
other people's shoes
so we want to do the most expedient
thing not always the right thing
and i think that's where as leaders you
can make a bit of a difference
is when you ask yourself actually if i
was in this person's shoes what would i
want someone to do
how would i someone want someone to
treat me
and then
do that
thank you jara
um we like to close view from the top
with a lightning round of questions oh i
have a few from you for you
is it better to be
an rj miller scholar or friend of rj
miller friend of rj miller
see you in vegas
[Music]
what was the last song you sang out loud
i know you love thinking
i got a feeling
tonight's gonna be a good time
it's always a good day to have a good
day
tunde or cody rixby both trick questions
both
i love all our instructors equally um
and then my last question what are you
most hopeful for
i'm most hopeful
for the future of the world you know
it's inspiring to me when i hear my
six-year-old or even my four-year-old
the other day we're having dinner
and
we ask we try we're trying to teach our
children how to have conversation so we
have these little cards and we ask
everybody a question and it's like if
you had to give a speech what would it
be about
my four-year-old said
it would be about painting the earth
i know very interesting right tell me
more
and and i asked you later the day i
talked to him about it and he was like
you know because i really care about the
earth and i really care about the
environment and it just it's just a
simple example into the next generation
they care so much about so many
important things like i was like when i
was four it was like cheetos or like
whatever snack they had in nigeria i
don't even think they had cheetos i
don't know what it was but like it's
like this generation cares so much so
deeply about equality about justice
about the environment right about things
that really matter and i'm hopeful about
that because you know what when people
care about something they take action
and they do something about it and that
means that you know
the world is going to continue to become
a better place and that leaves me
hopeful and inspired
that was excellent thank you thank you
thank you all so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you